c'est avec la force du nombre et leur
poids politique que les premiers
ministres des provinces et des
territoires tentent de faire pression
sur Ottawa ils veulent voir des
changements au système de libération
provisoire pour mieux protéger les corps
policiers dans une lettre envoyée au
Premier ministre Trudeau on peut élire
le système judiciaire doit absolument
empêcher toute personne qui représente
une menace pour la sécurité publique de
circuler librement
les premiers ministres demandent aussi
des changements concrets au Code
criminel notamment pour créer un
renversement du fardeau de la preuve en
matière de mise en liberté sous caution
pour les cas de possession d'une arme à
feu prohibée ils sortent publiquement
pour mettre le gouvernement Trudeau au
pied du mur d'une certaine manière et
bien faire comprendre à ce gouvernement
là que les discussions préalables qu'ils
ont eu sont sérieuses et qui s'attendent
à ce qui bouge une sortie politique qui
fait suite à d'autres missives envoyées
au gouvernement fédéral cette semaine
comme celle-ci de l'Association des
Directeurs de police du Québec qui
emboîtent le pas à d'autres associations
de chefs de police
et qu'on libère de plus en plus
rapidement et ça ça nous inquiète
l'inquiétude à monter d'un cran dans les
corps policiers à la suite de la mort
d'un confrère ontarien en décembre près
de Hamilton
des autochtones et des minorités
visibles et des communautés vulnérables
dans les pays financiers canadiens et
pour pallier à ça mais on veut enlever
les peines obligatoires et on veut
libérer les gens plus rapidement
possible une solution illogique pour
cette criminologue techniquement on
devrait subir la loi non pas en fonction
de l'ethnicité mais en fonction des
crimes commis elle souligne aussi que
les peines n'empêche pas les crimes
graves et que le problème devrait se
dénouer avant que des gestes
irréparables soient commis ici Carla
Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal